today on the matt welsh show the left is
now going after dr phil for allowing me
onto his show in the first place but if
they're confident in their position and
if they really believe in their own
gender ideology why should they be so
afraid of having the debate in the first
place also the march for life takes dc
by storm and the bite administration has
to trot out tom hanks to convince the
public that his first year in office was
not a complete disaster plus an old clip
of an msnbc host saying that your kids
don't belong to you goes viral again
what might we learn from it and m ms are
getting a more progressive and inclusive
rebranding for the year 2022 with this
final piece in place
utopia awaits we'll talk about all that
much more today on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
before we get going today i want to tell
you about uh new sponsors here at the
daily wire and big partners this year
naturally it's clean the great thing
about natural eats clean is that
they have a great product which we'll
tell you about in a second but also
they
they actually
are on our side in the culture they're
on our team
naturally it's clean is a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals their secret
powerful plant-based enzymes nature's
solution to cleaning when i say powerful
i'm talking about hospital-grade enzyme
cleaning power they have solutions for
almost every need in the house from the
kitchen to the bathroom to the laundry
room naturally it's clean has a
specialized formula to clean the area
effectively and i can tell you someone
with four kids i've got plenty of
opportunities um
to clean the house or at least my wife
does anyway and uh and that's why
naturally it's clean has become in big
handy and talking to the guys over
naturally it's clean i can tell you
again uh you know it's it's we
appreciate all of our sponsors but when
our sponsors are are
actually share our values it's a huge
bonus so i'm encouraging my listeners to
start with four of their top products
conveniently packaged together in their
daily wire essentials kit and for a
limited time my listeners can receive 15
off their order just enter promo code
matt at checkout when you visit
naturallyitsclean.com try these
incredible products in your home today
shipping is free and everything is made
right here in the usa again try our
naturally it's clean daily wire four
pack today by going to
naturallyitsclean.com and use promo code
mat to receive 15 off your purchase
don't delay make the smarter safer
choice for your home cleaning needs
today with naturally it's clean so it's
been a couple of days since uh my
episode of dr phil aired and i've read
and heard plenty of reactions to my
appearance and to the discussion that we
had on the show
and many of these reactions have been
quite angry
but the one thing i have not heard from
the angry side from my critics is any
sort of counter-argument
they're all quite sure that i'm wrong
and not just wrong but hateful and vile
and evil and dangerous
and yet none of them
i mean not a single one has been able to
explain why
they especially are unable or unwilling
to answer the question that has provoked
much of this outrage which of course is
what is a woman
instead the left finding itself unable
to answer my arguments
has directed its ire at dr phil for
allowing me to make the arguments in the
first place the daily wire has
catalogued some of these responses one
of them comes from matt bernstein the
social media influencer with a
significant following who goes by he
they pronouns by the way because
sometimes he's a man other times he's
two men apparently
and
he tweeted quote truly f dr phil for
this why would you invite a non-binary
person onto national television just to
be humiliated by an outspoken transphobe
who is this for
who does this help man f you dr phil
another guy who works in media hunter
lacey tweeted dr phil is always stirring
the pot this is so disrespectful why
does this man still have a show instead
of letting the actual queer voices speak
he's doing mental arithmetic to get to
get through his sentence i am fuming
yes let the queer voices speak he says
to which the rest of us may wonder when
exactly the queer voices ever stop
speaking i mean those are by far the
loudest voices in our society let the
queer voices speak what do they shut up
i mean come on
meanwhile drag queen nicolette new vogue
who was crowned miss gay omaha some
years back by the way a profound honor
no doubt screeched dear dr phil please
don't ever live tweet during rupaul's
drag race and act like an ally ever
again if you're gonna have people like
matt walsh on your show spreading
transphobia to the masses
sincerely the lgbt community and their
real allies
now i can't fathom what dr phil will do
with himself now if he's not allowed to
live tweet
during rupaul's drag race
i mean some punishments are simply too
much to bear imara jones founder of a
trans media company said this
dr phil inviting people on who compare
trans people to tomato plants continues
the idea that we aren't real which is
the basis for the murders and violence
against us matt walsh is the pied piper
of slick dismissiveness and this show is
not what we need
catherine caruso a writer for teen vogue
wrote you know dr phil has done a lot of
crappy things but having matt walsh on
to call trans people delusional and
mentally ill to their faces is a new low
especially since he frames it as a
debate with two valid opposing arguments
when it's really just transphobia
well catherine would you rather i say it
behind their backs
i mean you're right that i'll say all
this to anybody's face i don't change my
opinion
or my tone or approach based on the
audience
my view is my view and it'll be the same
all the time in front of anybody
on any platform in any context
that's called being honest
in any case you get the idea this is the
basic tenor of the response to my
appearance others called dr phil a
scumbag and a coward for allowing a
bigot a transphobe and a white
supremacist by the way to access his
platform apparently you're a white
supremacist now if you criticize leftist
gender ideology many of the criticisms
were similar to this from some guy named
brandt brickell who tweeted and f dr
phil for having matt walsh on the show
and giving him a platform to attack the
trans community under the guise of equal
debate
there is no debating someone's right to
exist
this is a common theme or rather strong
man
claiming that the debate was over the
existence of people who identify as
trans and that i was on the side either
claiming
that trans people do not exist at all or
else they do exist but should not be
allowed to
which which by the way that's not the
point
we all acknowledge i think everyone
acknowledges
that um people who identify as trans
exist
well we know that
that's that's why we're having this
discussion
the real question is does biological sex
exist
and if so what are the implications of
that
of course lgbt media got in on the
action outrage action as well the
website queerty has this headline dr
phil's show yesterday was a transphobic
train wreck and we don't even know where
to begin
the article explains that dr phil is now
on the hot seat for bringing me on his
show because quote to anyone who knows
him it should come as no surprise that
walsh came ready to spew transphobic
vitriol
he has a long history of transphobia
having offered the children authored the
children's book johnny the walrus which
compares being transgender to pretending
to be a walrus he also has a history of
homophobia having called pride month a
celebration of vanity well it is and
denounced adoption by same-sex couples
he's also defended the vigilante actions
of kyle rittenhouse he opposes abortion
imagine that and claims that doing yoga
is anti-christian i mean it is among
other things
i appreciate queerty by the way
cataloging all of my right opinions like
that and especially mentioning my number
one lgbt book johnny the walrus which is
available at johnnywalrus.com right now
and go pick up a copy lgbtq nation was
similarly incensed their headline dr
phil invited anti-transgender activists
to spread hate on tv
and it's painful to watch
not painful for me i quite enjoy it the
article claims that my job uh my job
quote depends on generating media
attention for for my anti-lgbtq antics
and that is true i admit i actually have
a little you know behind the scenes um
behind the curtain thing here i have a
certain number of anti-lgbtq antics
that i have to engage in each week
contractually it's written in the
contract
um and then on fridays i have a meeting
with the bosses where they review my
anti-anti-lgbtq antics catalog to see if
i met my quota now fortunately if i fall
short some weeks i do
i can make up for that by oppressing
some other marginalized group
and this is how it works in conservative
media the left suspicions are totally
accurate
but what about the rest of this what
about this idea
that the other side was trapped
humiliated by the simple fact that i was
allowed to sit on a stage with them and
speak to them
well we see here again the incredible
fragility
of the leftist position especially on
the issue of sex and gender
they like to accuse others of being
fragile fragile masculinity they call it
but what's more fragile than having to
insulate yourself from any direct
challenge to your worldview
if these people were confident in their
position
they'd be bragging that i was i was the
one who was humiliated
right they'd be they'd be patting my
good friend addison on the back and
giving the woke professor a high five
and congratulating them for for
defeating the transphobe in open
rhetorical combat
but you notice
interestingly how even the people on
their side are not attempting to claim
that their side was victorious
nobody's saying that not even them
instead they retreat into their
victimhood fortress
flinging insults from behind the walls
you know whenever there's an nfl game
you know i can always tell who lost even
without watching the game or checking
the score because the losing team
is the one whose fans are on social
media complaining about the refs
and something similar is happening here
except in this case the losing side is
complaining not just about the refs
but that the game was allowed to happen
in the first place
so imagine if the lions you know lost to
the vikings and then lions fans
responded by saying it was unfair and
traumatic to put the lions on the same
field as the vikings to begin with
that is how unfathomably weak and empty
and irrational the left's position is on
everything really but especially on this
their side collapses like a jenga tower
when it's directly challenged
and yet
it has won the culture anyway because
it's so rarely challenged
they use emotional blackmail
intimidation and coercion so effectively
that they've managed to conquer
civilization with an army that turns to
dust the moment you turn around and face
it
their gamble is that you never will
you'll just continue running away in
retreat
afraid of the loud noises they're making
but never calling their bluff
well i think
it's time to stop running
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
uh before we get to the headlines i
gotta mention this is a way more
important my my wife uh put me on blast
last night as the kids say or or did say
at one point
she was uh she was tweeting attacking me
while this is like while we were in bed
i thought she was asleep but she's over
there
uh
persecuting me on on the internet and
this is what she tweets she says matt
keeps our bedroom so cold at night it's
like the tundra i may have to wear an
overcoat to bed isn't this the age-old
debate between husbands and wives now
this is how pervasive cancel culture has
become that it's even made its way
into my marital bed
but this started a whole conversation
about the uh the correct temperature for
the bedroom and the house and who should
control it by the way the the right
answer there is a right answer the right
answer is that bedrooms should never be
above 62 degrees the rest of the house
should never go above 65. really it's
it's best to have both below 60 ideally
that's especially true at night when
you're sleeping so i set the house very
cold i also have an overhead fan and a
box fan blowing directly on me because
the best way to sleep is to just be on
the verge of hypothermia the entire time
i found but here's the thing
this is an important discussion that
especially you women in the audience
could benefit from hearing because i
know women often complain
about being cold and so there's this
controversy about who should get to
determine the temperature
so here it is
two things
first of all i get to control the
temperature
because i'm i'm the warmest
and the warmest one should decide not
the hottest
or so i mean not like the hottest in
terms of appearance because then i would
by that limits test i would never win
but the warmest like physically
because there's only so many if you want
to if you're warm and you want to
regulate your temperature there's only
so much you can do
without adjusting the environment
there's only so many layers you can take
off
this is especially true in public like
at work or at the dentist in the waiting
room or something if you're cold at work
you can wear as many sweaters and
jackets as you want you can put on
earmuffs and
mittens if you want that's not an hr
violation i can only take off so much
before someone calls the police
so that's why i should get to decide
what the temperature is but there's also
a second point and this is the more
important point
and it's going to be tough to hear this
but i'm the man
and so as the man
as men
we have the special right
and responsibility to be in control of
the temperature in any building that
we're in
why well because and don't take this the
wrong way
but women you're too fickle to be in
control of the thermostat same goes for
the volume on tv
because you can't make up your mind i'll
be watching tv with my wife and suddenly
after 47 minutes she'll shout it's too
loud turn it down
getting mad at me for a volume that was
acceptable to both of us
for the better part an hour of an hour
and now all of a sudden it's a problem
and then i'll turn it down and what
happens five minutes later she says i
can't hear it can you turn it up
similar thing happens with a thermostat
so if she controlled it it would be
adjusted every 15 minutes until our hvac
system exploded
with me as the man there is consistency
you know that the house is always going
to be cold enough to cause frostbite you
know the tv is always going to be loud
enough to rupture your eardrums it may
not be pleasant it may not be
comfortable it may not be reasonable it
may not be safe
but it's consistent it's steady it's
reliable
okay and furthermore ephesians 5
wives submit to your husband as to the
lord
i've used that on my wife too with the
thermostat conversation
doesn't always go well all right we'll
start with this march for life the march
for life is currently underway um
started at uh at about noon in dc
and
a couple of
things that you always know with the
march for life and the first is that
you're not going to hear much about it
um from from corporate media because
there's just no way for them they have
no choice but to acknowledge it
because it's it's right in their
backyard it's right outside their window
there are hundreds of thousands of
people marching that's been this way for
over 40 years every single year
consistently and so they have no choice
but to at least acknowledge it but
they're going to acknowledge it as
quickly as they can now as we know of
course um
you put 500 000 or a million
pro-lifers at the march for life
marching and they're gonna get a
five-second mention you know um
but you take a fraction of that crowd
say like 50 and they're marching for
blm or whatever some leftist thing and
and uh that's suddenly front page
headline news so we know that's how it
goes
um
the attendance will always be
underestimated
in fact i was just reading an article i
can't remember which which uh which uh
outlet it was but saying that uh you
know organizers estimate that uh
typically there's around 50 000 people
attending the march for life yeah i
don't know 50 000
you know multiply that by 10 perhaps
hundreds of thousands of people come to
the march for life every single year and
what makes that so impressive is number
one that it's every single year
this is by far the largest
um
annual political rally
in american history there's never been
anything like it now there have been
other marches where you have one
particular march that draws a greater
crowd than the marks for life does on
average
but no one has been able to sustain that
for anywhere near as long as the march
for life has again
in into the fourth well into the fourth
decade
so the attendance is always going to be
um
always going to be under underestimated
and they're not going to show you
uh or they're going to be very sparing
in
showing you images from the crowd
you know and they're going to try to the
other thing they'll do is they'll report
it as and i guarantee you're going to
see headlines like this uh something
like
people on
protesters on both sides of the abortion
debate
show up in washington d.c
yeah protesters on both sides because
there's there's 500 000 pro-lifers and
um
you know three
pro-abortion people and then that that
that equates to
protesters on both sides but they're not
going to show you the crowd
or they're going to be very sparing in
what they are very selective in what
they show
because what they don't want you to
notice
is that the march for life is very very
young
it's a very young crowd
now i would having been to the march for
life many times i would estimate that
certainly the vast majority are
certainly under 40 and uh many are under
30 even under 20. so this is a very
young crowd the the pro-life movement is
a young movement
and also
though i hesitate to point this out
because it sounds like i'm trying to
appeal to the left on their own terms
which which i'm very against doing but i
will mention i will say that in fact
it's a very diverse crowd as well
actually diverse because it simply is
you go to the march for life really any
any pro-life event but especially the
march for life because you got people
from all over the country going
and um all different kinds of people
from different walks of life
are are there
because as it turns out
you know you don't need to be an old
white conservative not that there's
anything wrong with being an old white
conservative but you don't have to be
that
to believe that it's not okay to kill
babies
this is a position that is appealing
to um
people of all
of all stripes
and it's this is another example of the
kind of debate
that the left doesn't want to have
i mean how often have you even seen
you could certainly turn on cable news
and you're going to hear pro-abortion
talking points and you're going to hear
abortion discussed
but how often on a mainstream platform
have you seen
that debate really happen where the
pro-abortion side is actually challenged
very similar to the gender issue
it doesn't happen because they know they
can't really defend it
they know it's an indefensible position
isn't it it's indefensible
scientifically
the idea that these uh these unborn
babies aren't human or they don't count
as people scientifically makes no sense
i mean logically
we've always known that the babies in
the womb are our people and our human
beings and our living
but as technology progresses and we're
able to see more and more what's
actually happening in the womb during
pres pregnancy
it only serves to each day further
vindicate
and while invalidating further further
vindicate the pro-life side while
invalidating the pro-abortion side so
they can't engage with it scientifically
and they can't really engage with it
morally either
because when it comes down to it
ultimately you are arguing for killing
innocent people
you have one side which says it's never
okay to kill an innocent and defenseless
person that's why we're against abortion
the other side who says you know
sometimes it is okay
but only if that innocent and
defenseless person is a baby
so um that's the marks for life we'll go
here joe biden has really gotten himself
into another bind and another pickle by
by openly claiming that our elections
are rigged and illegitimate after a year
of condemning trump for saying exactly
the same thing so it's been a bit of a
pr nightmare and that's why the white
house
has trotted out their secret weapon
to mop up the mess their their smooth
talking damage control expert camila
harris so let's see how she handles
questioning on this issue
let's talk about another comment the
president made he openly cast doubt on
whether the 2022 midterm elections would
be legitimate he said it all depends um
which is astonishing to hear
a president question whether our
elections will be legitimate we've heard
it before but not from this president
is he really concerned that that we may
not have fair and free elections
the president has been consistent on
this issue and the issue at hand the
issue i was there last night
in the chamber of the senate
and the issue is that there are two
bills
the john lewis voting rights act and the
freedom to vote act
that have been the the solution that has
been offered to address the fact that
around our country states have put in
place laws that are purposely making it
more difficult for the american people
to vote
okay so no answer there
um
are the elections actually going to be
free and fair and legitimate or not
and um we heard the word astonishing
though the only thing astonishing going
on here because it's not really
astonishing it's not it's not actually
astonishing to have joe biden
questioning the legitimacy of the
elections
because we know that he is a soulless
mindless
um
goon so that's not astonishing the
astonishing thing
is that the media or it might seem
astonishing at first until we understand
what's really happening here but the
media is actually
taking them to task for this
same thing happened when you watch the
press conference however much of that
you could stomach watching
the media they were actually asking
some real questions
a few anyway
and so let's watch a little bit more of
this as the anchor continues to actually
press her on on this question listen
does he think now that these bills
haven't been passed that the 22 midterms
won't be legitimate or fair or free
let's not conflate issues so what we are
looking at and and the topic of so much
debate last night
was that we as america cannot afford to
allow this blatant erosion of our
democracy and in particular the right of
all americans who are eligible to vote
to have access to the ballot unfettered
that is the topic of the conversation
and let's not be distracted by the
political gamesmanship when what is
truly at stake
or are issues like whether americans
with disability have the opportunity to
vote by mail
um
yeah
again only astonishing thing is that the
media is challenging actually
challenging her on this
and why are they doing that well i think
the answer is that uh they they want
the biden administration gone they want
biden gone
um they want him primaried
they they know he's gonna lose if he
actually if he actually runs again in
2024 which if he's physically still on
earth he will
because he's power obsessed and power
hungry like all these people and this is
all he cares about that's the whole
reason that he ran for office at the age
of 78 anyway
um
but they won't they want them going they
want they want this administration going
they want someone else put in there and
so they they are actually
for totally self-serving reasons that's
what we have to understand it's not
because they care about integrity it's
not because they care about ethics or
they have any real passion for doing
real journalism
just for for
their own reasons self-interest
and their own ideological reasons
they want biden gone so i think we're
gonna see probably more scenes like this
um moving on you know you know democrat
politicians are sometimes accused of
being out of touch elitist narcissistic
that's that's not really fair i mean
listen to this truly humble moment from
nancy pelosi yesterday listen to this
here's the thing i say to my members
on a regular basis
when we gather in caucus and as you know
sometimes it's
hybrid these days but any time we have
gathered in caucus when we're actually
virtually or hybrid i've said to them
under this roof figuratively or actually
is the greatest collection
of intellect
integrity
and imagination for doing the right
thing for the american people
i have great
confidence in the contegrity of my
members
they
are remarkable
so when people talk about well somebody
might do this and somebody i
i think i i trust our members if in fact
we should have severe uh penalties for
delay and reporting on stock up then do
that i've said to the the house
administration committee review all the
bills that are coming in and see which
ones
where where the support is in our caucus
we heard more of that than we needed to
uh the greatest collection of integrity
and intelligence
in the world
is
in among the democrats in congress
if that's true then we are absolutely
doomed and in fact we are doomed but
that's still not true you could find a
greater collection of intelligence and
integrity just going to the
you know going to the dmv or waiting in
line at walmart um
the the bars is very very low there but
this is actually how this is a rare
moment
she claims they have integrity and they
don't but there are moments of honesty
at least if unintentional this is a real
rare moment of honesty
where she shows
how they see themselves and how they see
everybody else they really believe that
they are better than the rest of us
that comes as no surprise it's just
pretty rare that you hear a politician
actually come out and say
we're better than all of you
amazing
finally joe biden has um
a plan to convince everyone it seems
like he had the worst first year of any
president in american history which is
not hyperbole but merely an observation
everything is demonstrably worse
by every category every measure
everything is worse now
and
specifically because of what this
administration has done
um
but
how they're going to convince people
that it's not that the truth is not what
they see staring them in the face
well what do you do you bring in tom
hanks to narrate yeah you have a little
video tom hanks narration some
inspirational music we'll play some just
keep the mic open because i don't know
how long how much of this i can actually
stomach we'll have to cut it off but
let's watch
some of tom hanks convincing us that
actually
this past year of your life was amazing
for there was always light if only we're
brave enough to see it if only we're
brave enough
to be it
if only we're brave enough brave enough
to live through two of the most
difficult years many of us can remember
brave enough to pull ourselves up again
and again
america is the home of the brave it's
why we keep getting up no matter how
many times we get knocked down
like with our economy it isn't all the
way back but it's getting stronger we
may be entering year three of a pandemic
none of us wanted or expected but were
moving i was the first person to get the
vaccine in the whole country and now
how many people are vaccinated over 200
million right that's what keeps me going
that i can feel the change restaurants
have opened their doors shops and
businesses are buzzing again all over
bravery
showing the bravery of americans by
people wearing masks outside
okay
even tom hanks can't do it maybe they
should try morgan freeman you got to
bring in the big guns now
uh i mean you know oftentimes all it
takes is a tom hanks narration of morgan
freeman narration and some inspirational
music in the background
to convince convince anybody of anything
but um that's that's not good now of
course he's talking about the qualities
of the american people and uh
even if what he said was true it would
that wouldn't speak at all to this
administration
but unfortunately i mean there are
plenty of brave people in america
but um
collectively
you know it's it's
it's
hard to look at the last two years and
give us all as a group credit for
bravery and
courage and ironically that video kind
of demonstrated why
talking about the bravery and courage of
americans and then showing
a bunch of cowardly
paranoid hypochondriacs wearing masks
outside along with children who are
being forced to wear them because of the
paranoid cowardly hypochondriacs in
their lives
so i'm still not convinced somehow all
right let's play another club now this
clip went viral yesterday though it's
actually from way back in 2013. it's
melissa perry if you remember her
i don't but maybe you do she was on
msnbc uh back a few years ago
and back then she said this now
what's
well we'll play it first and then we'll
talk about it again this is this is
several years old but i think i think
the fact that it's old there's an
important point
um to be made about that but let's play
it first
we have
never invested as much in public
education as we should have because
we've always had kind of a private
notion of children your kid is yours and
totally your responsibility we haven't
had a very collective notion of these
are our children so part of it is we
have to break through our kind of
private idea that kids belong to their
parents or kids belong to their families
and recognize that kids belong to whole
communities once it's everybody's
responsibility and not just the
households then we start making better
investments
we have to break down this pr this
private idea of children the kids belong
to the entire community and as always
just like when they see the public in
public school doesn't really mean public
it means specifically the state
uh this is
government school so when she says
community she doesn't mean community she
means the government that's that's uh
those words are synonyms as far as she's
concerned the amazing thing though
is um this is in 2013 and it this was
not like
something she said off the cuff
on on one of her shows it's not
something that she was caught saying it
was you know it wasn't like a hot mic
moment
this was a a promo they
they put this as a as a promo and they
ran it as a commercial
for the network they were so proud of it
saying your kids don't belong to you
so what we could take away from this is
that they
the left has been working to take away
parental rights for a long time
and they've been very open about it
the only difference is that recently
much of the right has finally noticed
now there are some of us who have been
screaming about this for years you know
since that melissa harris perry video
and before
especially people who homeschool the
homeschool community um is is quite
aware of
you know the government's and the left's
attitude towards people who take charge
of their own
kids education
but this all this shows is that um
this recent emphasis on parental rights
all that is that is a product
of conservatives
finally waking from their stupor
on this issue it is not a product it is
not that the left
in the last year has been suddenly more
aggressive
in going after parental rights
if anything they've been a little bit
more subtle about it
with some exceptions you know terry
mcauliffe saying
parents shouldn't decide what their kids
are taught that that's that's another
good example because he said that off
the cuff
and you could tell he immediately
regretted saying it out loud after he
said it
go back about 10 years ago and they were
saying this stuff's scripted openly
in commercials
so this has been happening for a very
very long time
and for the record of course no my kids
do not belong to the community
they belong to me
um
not as property not like in the way you
would say your car belongs to you
but in the sense that it is my sacred
and solemn responsibility to care for
them
and also
i care about my children
more than anybody else
my wife and i care about our children
more than anybody else does
what is one of the reasons there are a
lot of reasons why i will not
surrender my kids to the community or
rely on the community to care for them
a lot of reasons
one is i don't trust
the quote community which again means
government
to take care of my kids
i don't believe in their values
um i'm not going to entrust my children
to be morally formed
by the quote
community but then also it's because i
recognize
that the community
referring both to the government and the
actual community
doesn't care about my kids the way that
i do
you could say all you want oh we all
they're all our kids no but you actually
don't care about my kids that much
because they're not yours
i mean you might care about my kids in
theory
in the sense that you care about all
kids and you want everyone to have a
happy and nice life
but
i wake up every day
and
my kids are the first thing i think
about
right this is a constant presence in my
life constantly at the front of my mind
as parents as a parent i live every day
taking care of my kids i've structured
my life around that around my kids
specifically not around kids as a
general concept but my kids
so i know them and care about them more
than anybody else
so that's another really good reason why
i'm not going to surrender them to the
community
it's also it's also a really good reason
to take care of your kids education
if you can do it and start homeschooling
because you know your kid better than
anybody
and you care about them you send them to
school and um
you know there are plenty of really good
teachers there's a lot of bad ones but
there are plenty of really good ones but
even the really good ones your kid is
their job
and
if they're good then they do care about
making sure a kid has a has a good
education but they can only afford to
care so much
and in most public schools they've got
you know 30 other kids in class that's
just one class
so your kid is one in this assembly line
that they care about as much as they can
it's just not much
and they certainly don't know your kid
like you do
all right one other club i wanted to
play this is a this is an account uh the
account woke preacher clips on twitter
kind of like the libs of tiktok but for
christians uh dug up this clip of simon
woodman he's
of london's bloomsbury central baptist
church at some kind of panel discussion
talking about jesus
and uh informing us that apparently
jesus may be to know this was
transgender
i think jesus um transgenders himself on
a number of occasions
um i i think you know just just a little
phrase that jesus is lamenting over
jerusalem longing to gather jerusalem as
a mother hen gathers her chicks
and i think if you look at the foot
washing from john's gospel footwashing
elsewhere in both old and new testament
that it's consistently done by by women
and yet jesus takes that on people often
cast that as being the servant's role it
was the woman's role
and and jesus does it and becomes the
woman at that point
so transgender is a verb now too jesus
transgendered himself
i play that clip because it perfectly
captures
how transgender ideology reinforces
gender norms
while pretending to
deconstruct them
so jesus becomes the woman
by taking on the quote woman's role
but why not just say that jesus proves
that the role is not just a woman's role
which
it isn't
why is it that jesus's sex changes
because of the role
rather than saying the role changes
because of
his sex
you see what i'm saying what why it's
like when a when a boy plays with
the example i used in doctorville boyd
plays with a dollhouse
you know
and for for decades
back when the left really did seem to be
and you know the feminists were more in
control of gender ideology back then and
so there was this emphasis on breaking
down gender roles and everything and so
they would have said back then that a
boy plays with the dollhouse and uh all
that does is prove that boys can play
with dollhouses and it's not just a girl
thing
okay so they the um this idea that
dollhouses are just for girls is an
artificial social construct and so this
boy is helping to break it down by
playing with the dollhouse
well now they say that when the boy
plays the dollhouse it's an indication
that he's actually a girl
so you are reinforcing that stereotype
and by him engaging in that activity you
know playing that role
it actually changes him rather than him
changing the role or the nature of the
role the role changes the nature of him
and so things have been flipped around
exactly backwards upside down
perfect example of it there
let's get out of the comment section
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
all right uh dailywire.com sweet baby
comments if you want to leave a video
comments and uh i have not seen these
yet but we're just gonna
um i entrusted mckenna to compile the
video comments so
blame her if these are not the good ones
let's uh let's watch
hello to the handsome and brilliant
sweet daddy welsh my name is rachel and
i'm from brighton michigan i just wanted
to share a proud parenting moment with
you that i had this week my
nine-year-old daughter lacey came home
the other day from school and said that
a boy in her class was wearing a t-shirt
with a panda on it
lacey made the appropriate comment panda
shouldn't exist
this really threw her fourth grade
classmates for a loop and they all
started asking her what she had against
pandas and you know they were so cute
and why didn't she like them
fortunately being a junior member of the
sweet baby gang she was under no
obligation to respond
just wanted you to know that i am doing
my part to indoctrinate the next
generation keep up the great work sbg
for life
that that almost brought tear to my eye
that was that that is uh that's amazing
and um uh the the fact that
not just that we're getting the sweet
baby getting out there but that we're
spreading the word on these really
important issues like the utter
uselessness of pandas that that i think
is uh is incredible the only thing is i
i would sit down with your daughter
and um you know she has the lines so
she's been indoctrinated into the
anti-panda
community
but i think the next step
is to be able to go out there and
evangelize to this position and and
explain why the pandas are useless so
maybe that's a conversation you could
sit down and have with her that's that's
uh that's wonderful
let's check out another one
hello mr matt walsh my name is ari
ginsberg i use all pronouns every single
one of them i must know i have had
sleepless nights over this what is your
workout routine please tell me thank you
very much and sweet baby gang for life
my work hour table over the last uh i'd
say six months my workout routine is uh
you know walking up and down steps when
i'm putting my kids to bed that's pretty
much what it's what has been
what's
that's that's that's been the entire
thing i don't know why
and i do got to get back back to the gym
and back to working out but um
it's as much of a mystery to me as maybe
as to you that i'm not
100 pounds heavier i don't know why i'm
not extremely fat i don't it's it's not
because of any effort on my part my diet
is terrible i just eat whatever i want
um
and somehow
and people keep telling me that event
you know eventually your your metabolism
slows down so one day i'm just going to
balloon i'm going to come in here one
day and be like 350 pounds it's just
going to happen overnight but it hasn't
happened yet so
that's it let's watch one more
my sweet sweet
sweet daddy
i come before you in solidarity in my
cold truck
my polka dotted polo
my name is weston and my pronouns are
life liberty and the pursuit of proper
voting restrictions
uh my question comes to you around the
catholic faith i am not catholic but i
do have several friends that are
uh growing up you had some of your
friends that were catholic and name only
and some that were pretty devout
and what i did notice is the friends
that are pretty strict with the catholic
faith
look at the pope in the same way that i
see the left looked at dr fauci
you know fauci says he's the science and
the pope is the faith
so my question to you as a devout
catholic man and cult leader
what is your view on the position of the
pope and the catholic faith
and how do you as a very conservative
uh minded person
uh uphold the catholic doctrine even
when the figurehead espouses pretty
left-leaning ideologies
thank you sir
spg for life
uh yeah well first of all i gotta say
that thanks for the comment and it is it
is i i have discovered with these video
comments that um
the the sweet daddy walsh thing it's
it's a whole other ball game when i can
actually
see and hear the person calling me that
and it's it it's like an extra element
of weirdness but that's that's fine you
know i'll get through that part of it as
far as the pope goes um
fortunately
and this is this is something that
catholics were constantly having to
explain
or at least the catholics who understand
their own faith and part of the problem
is that many catholics do not and
they're the ones who create this
confusion so i don't blame non-catholics
for not understanding this but
fortunately um
we are not obligated to agree with the
pope
on his positions on
various subjects
um
you know the pope has has his own views
and his own ideas and i i happen to
think that this pope is wrong about very
many things i think he's fundamentally
wrong in his basic world view as well
and i'm allowed to think that i'm not
required to say anything otherwise
um
every the the pope's every
pronouncement is not an infallible
declaration
now there is some disagreement among
catholics and theologians about uh how
many infallible declarations have
actually been made by popes and there's
discussion about how many it is but
however many it is it's a very small
number actually
and um so this pope just kind of
speaking off the cuff or even
standing up at mass and giving a homily
i'm not required to agree with any of it
and i don't
i very much disagree with this pope on
almost everything that he seems to say
uh at least when it comes to his
ideology and his uh in his worldview
um
you know part part of the problem is
that because you could always ask well
have there been popes in the past
who you would have disagreed with just
as much probably
but the issue is that we we are now in a
position
both because of 24-hour media and the
internet and also because of this pope's
propensity for just babbling we're in a
position to to constantly hear
everything he has to say about
everything
he's he's constantly talking about about
things he'll be on a plane and just you
know
talking to reporters
and um
and so he loves to talk and we can hear
it
and so we're constantly subjected to
to it
but
i i very much disagree and that's and
i'm perfectly within my rights as a
catholic to do that all right a couple
of written comments from ryan listermann
says matt delivered such savage mic
drops his opponents had to change their
pronouns to was were
that's good
that might be my favorite comment of all
time
incredibly well done we should send you
a prize
can we do that send them a t-shirt or
something
maybe if we can we'll send you one uh
iron man says the fact that they were
traumatized by a debate is 100 proof
they need mental help
um
i actually don't think it's it's proof
of that i think you let
them off the hook by saying that they
need mental help or whatever um i think
it's it is evidence of the flimsiness
and fragility as we were talking about
of their worldview
and the fact that they are aware that
it's flimsy and fragile
david says why is matt so obsessed with
the transgender issue
the lady duth protests too much methinks
sorry i meant gentlemen somebody needs
to check the back of matt's closet for
panties bras and corsets
so what are you implying so i talk about
it uh because i'm secretly trans is what
is what you're saying
well you got me it's true i am
actually i i uh
you're but you've you've got it
backwards though because i i'm i'm a
woman originally and i underwent
the most convincing transition of all
time
you got me it's 100 true and now that my
secret is out
i have the social credit to say whatever
i want about the trans issue
and you can't criticize me transphobe so
checkmate
as the beloved author of the
best-selling children's book lgbtq plus
children's book i should say johnny the
walrus i am now a very important voice
in the transgender conversation that's
why i was invited to dr phil to discuss
these most important issues with experts
who could not even tell me what a woman
was here's a clip of my enlightening
experience
that's a question i would like to throw
out to other members of the panel
actually because just like the
four-year-old can't answer what is a
girl
well this is one of the problems with
this left-wing gender ideology is that
no one who espouses it
can even tell you what these words mean
like what is a woman
can you tell me what a woman is
no i can't
because it's not for me to say i
womanhood looks different for everybody
what do you what do you define a woman
as an adult human female and what does a
female mean
uh
someone with female reproductive organs
okay someone who's you know here's the
thing when you're when you're a female
it goes right down to your bones your
dna so that's why if someone
dies we can dig up their bones a hundred
years from now we have no idea what they
believed in their head but we can tell
what sex they were because it's in it's
down in it's it's ingrained in every
fiber of their being interesting so i'm
trying to understand your definition is
that a woman is someone who is female
you said right correct is a biological
female so what happens if we have maybe
someone who is female identifies as a
woman right you know cisgender woman
right as you explain as you just
explained
it maybe doesn't have the ability to
reproduce
maybe it doesn't have those organs that
you're talking about that are
reproductive organs i have answered the
question
you stood up here and said trans women
are women yes tell me what you mean what
is a womanhood is something that just as
ethan explained i cannot define because
i am not myself use the word so what did
you mean when you said trans women are
women if you don't know what it means
right so here's the thing so i do not
define what a woman is because i do not
identify as a woman womanhood is
something that is an umbrella term it
includes people that describes what
people who identify as a woman i
identify as what as a woman what is that
was to each their own each woman each
man each person is going to have a
different relation with their own gender
identity and define it differently
are women too okay
and you want to hold up transfer
what you won't even tell me what you
want to do means though so you want to
reduce women you want to reduce men down
to maybe just their genetics our
genitals our chromosomes right that's
what you want to do is that's what you
what you want to do is appropriate women
you want to appropriate womanhood okay
and turn it into basically a costume
that could be worn
if you want to learn more about toxic
transgender ideology pick up a copy of
my best-selling children's book johnny
the walrus about a boy who believes he's
a walrus and in the internet mob who
tells his mother to respect his trans
walrus identity johnny the walrus sold
out in 48 hours when it was released but
don't worry more copies are on the way
you can reserve yours now at
amazon.com or go to johnnywalrus.com
luke roziak the daily wire journalist
who broke the big national story about
sexual abuse in loudoun county schools
has a new book out exposing public
schools it's called race to the bottom
uncovering the secret forces destroying
america's public school system you can
pre-order it at amazon today it includes
the never-before-told story of america's
first woke school system which was in
seattle tracy castro gill the director
of ethnic studies at seattle public
schools turned math into math ethnic
studies where students must explain how
math is used to oppress and marginalize
people in communities of color
math is used i mean i always felt
depressed as by math when i was in
school but i'm you know white by spring
2018 the math ethnic studies program was
piloted in six schools on the next state
math exam the performance of black
students at those schools plummeted the
state named tracy regional teacher of
the year for 2018 2019 and they're
employing her methods all over the
country to learn more about this and so
much else pre-order a copy of luke
rosiak's book race to the bottom
uncovering the secret forces destroying
america's public school system today at
amazon now let's go to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well the world rejoiced yesterday when
candy maker mars incorporated announced
that it would be rebranding m ms to make
them more inclusive and progressive for
the year 2022 as part of their quote
global commitment to creating a world
where everyone feels they belong and
society is inclusive
this is one of the one of the final
pieces necessary to usher in an age of
harmony and tranquility now all we need
is for the patriarchal gender
essentialist mike and ikes and the
violent and triggering pop rocks to
finally evolve as well
we are on the cusp of utopia
so close i can taste it
tastes sweet and has 35 grams of sugar
per serving nobody expected that
civilization could be saved
by junk food brands
but they've been at the the front lines
in the battle against bigotry for a long
time actually it began two years ago
when gushers tweeted in support of blm
uh they tweeted gushers wouldn't be
gushers without the black community and
your voices we're working with fruit by
the foot on creating space to amplify
that we see you we stand with you
prior to this statement most people had
never thought about the intersectional
relationship between fruit snacks and
racial justice but the dream team of
fruit by the foot and gushers changed
all of that
junk food brands have been leading the
charge ever since and brands in general
have remained at the forefront and the
struggle for tolerance and equality we
talked yesterday about about a audi's ad
promoting gender sensitive language
every day another brand steps up the
brands are our guiding light the brands
will show us the way the brands will
save us
or so we hope
but sadly
as i read more
about eminem's alleged efforts to
promote inclusion and diversity i found
myself unsatisfied
come to think of it we even need to ask
some questions about gushers
whatever happened to the space that it
was supposed to make to amplify black
voices that was two years ago
i have not heard any black voice
amplified by a fruit snack in the two
years since
i've seen black people buy fruit snacks
i've seen them eat fruit snacks i
haven't seen the fruit snack do anything
for them though
the fruit snack just sits there
passively waiting to be consumed
its silence is deafening it silences
violence
what about m m's well the vp of the
company appeared on the website cheddar
news where all important news is
reported to talk about the brand's
mission and vision for the year ahead
here she is explaining how eminem's she
hopes will spark a movement and change
the world
m ms is on a mission to create a world
where everyone feels they belong we're
wanting to start a movement to remind
everyone that despite our differences we
have an incredibly powerful thing in
common as a community which is the power
of fun
it's actually a reaffirmation a concrete
commitment to what we've always believed
as a brand
that the power of fun is the most
important way that we can help people
feel included and increase that sense of
belonging and as you mentioned as a
reflection of that you're going to see
our brand evolve in its look and feel to
reflect a dynamic and the dynamic and
progressive world that we're living in
sounds promising um there's nothing
lofty about a brand of candy promising
to fundamentally change and reshape
society in fact historians agree that a
great number of the major revolutions in
human history have been sparked by
different types of candies the reese's
revolution of 1645 just one example but
let's listen to their to their actual
plan because here's where things go off
the rails a little bit i think
how will m m's be more inclusive exactly
listen
so as an iconic brand that's been around
for actually over 80 years it's really
important that we're evolving over time
as well and one of the most powerful
ways we can do that is through our
beloved characters you'll see them as
we've done a deep look at them both
inside as well as out
in terms of reflecting new looks
personalities and backstories for
example green you'll see her better
reflect empowerment and confidence and
be known for more than just her shoes
you're going to see green and brown
together being a supporting force for
women who are throwing shine and not
shade you'll also see orange really
embrace his true self worries and all
and not be afraid to express it we
actually know orange is the most
relatable of our characters in the crew
it's based on some conversations we've
had with gen z which we know is the most
anxious generation and beyond our
characters you'll see things such as our
increased
color palette as well as the different
sizes and shapes of our lentils and a
personal favorite of mine are more of an
emphasis on the ampersand it's a
distinctive element of the m m's logo
that connects the two m's together and
it's really a signal of our belief as a
brand that we are better together
well
look there's no question that women
across the country will be uplifted and
empowered by the green and brown eminem
now the support of these two
anthropomorphized pieces of candy will
be crucial to women in fact not but a
week ago i came into the living room and
i found my wife collapsed on the couch
in tears i asked her what was wrong
and she told me that she didn't feel
supported by the green m m and all i
could do was hold her and weep with her
now m m's have addressed this problem
and that is
admirable and important
and there's likewise no doubt that we
all will derive inspiration from the
orange m m as he embraces his true self
it's always been clear to me that the
orange eminem was repressing his true
identity hiding his truth away in fear
and it brings me comfort to know that
he'll finally be able to live
authentically but with all that said
m m's have still dropped the ball
significantly
first of all it is unconscionable that
in the year 2022 there still is no overt
lgbt representation in the eminem
community
perhaps the true self stuff is supposed
to hint at the orange m m sexuality but
but mere hinting is not even close to
good enough
we have to know in very precise terms
about the orange m m's sexual identity
and gender expression is he gay is he
bisexual is he a trans eminem is he a
genderqueer non-binary transmasculine
two-spirit demisexual the fact that he's
still forced to keep this part of
himself locked away only shows at m m's
as a company
is not serious in its commitment to
diversity and inclusion
indeed its erasure of lgbt identities is
a direct assault on an already
marginalized community which has been
waiting too long for candy brand
representation further while we can
appreciate the fact that there is a
brown eminem which serves to validate
black and brown bodies
still there has not been any ad campaign
so far as i'm aware
dealing with systemic racism or police
brutality we have not seen an ad for
example where the brown m m is racially
profiled during a traffic stop
is that because the m m's brand denies
that the black community is subject to
such persecution
or do they just not care enough to
acknowledge this reality in their ad
campaigns which is at m m's
this is all to say nothing of the fact
that still even now in the year 2022
they haven't introduced a line of m ms
where the m is written in braille for
the sake of the visually impaired
this continued oversight effectively
makes it impossible for blind people to
eat m ms a problem that could be solved
by litigation or legislation if congress
could get its act together but which is
you know a truly inclusive company would
address on its own
of course this is part of a long history
of eminem ableism
for a long time their motto was if you
remember melts in your mouth not in your
hand
completely ignoring the fact that some
americans don't have hands
so it's clear that eminem's commitment
to progress equity and inclusion is
tentative at best
disingenuous at worst this rebrand is an
improvement
it doesn't go nearly far enough
all i can say to m m's is this
listen
to marginalized communities
hear what they're saying
and do the work
until then you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today and
the week
have a great weekend talk to you on
monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
wadowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin
[Music]